I do have a problem with
>> exactly
>> the the the the the pope and they say,
you know, I don't and I get stuck on
that. I know.
>> You know why, brother?
>> Go ahead.
>> Because you're a babe in the faith. You
don't have that depth of knowledge in
the Bible and you don't know much church
history. So something's going to trouble
you due to the way you understand the
Bible.
>> Right?
>> Doesn't mean it's wrong. It means that
you haven't been given the full picture.
For example, I Okay, let me go into
that. Now,
here's where non-denominational
Christians will misinterpret the Bible
to demonize not just the Catholic Church
because even the Orthodox have icons.
Okay, I'm going to give you this
article, but we're going to go through
it. Did God really say you shouldn't
have a statue? We don't call idol
because idol is the wrong term. An idol
meant like a false god,
>> right?
>> That's not what he said. Look what he
said. Okay, let's go through this step
by step. You ready?
>> Okay, here it is. And I'm gonna get you
the article in a minute, but before I do
that, let's go through it step by step.
Exodus 20 verse 1 to5. Now God spoke all
these things, saying, I am the Lord your
God, who brought you out out of the land
of Egypt, out of the house of bondage.
You shall have no other gods. Now,
here's the key. You shall not have
another god before me. You shall not
make for yourself any graven idol or any
likeness of anything that is in heaven
above or that is in the earth beneath.
Now notice heaven above, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Or that is in the water below the
earth. You shall not bow down to them or
serve them. What is he going about
making images of creatures that you
worship as gods? Right.
>> Correct.
>> So if you make an image of a creature
and you say that's God, that's idolatry.
Correct.
>> Right.
>> Because I'm going to show you God tells
you you can have images. But before I do
that, do you think there's a Catholic on
in this planet or an Orthodox in this
planet, they know their faith that they
think Mary's a goddess?
>> No. Only the Trinity is God.
>> So when a Catholic has a statue of the
Holy Mother or an Orthodox, that's the
same thing as you having a portrait of
your mother and you kiss it.
>> Okay.
>> Do you have a picture of your mother at
home? I don't have any pictures, but I
know what you mean.
>> You get my point, right? Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Or when you go and visit the grave and
you see the tombstone of a loved one and
you put flowers and you speak to that
tombstone, are you committing grave
worship?
>> No. No. Because you just it's their
memory, not
>> you're recognizing that person though
the body's there, they're alive, and
you're talking to them because that
means instinctually you believe God will
let them know that you're talking to
them.
But but didn't is doesn't the Bible say
that the dead know nothing?
>> You sure? So when Jesus says Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob are not dead, but
they're alive.
>> And when Jesus says, "Whatever me never
dies."
>> Oh, makes sense. Right.
>> All right. But let's go step by step. So
here, what is it that God doesn't want
you to have? An idol of a god or a
goddess that you worship as a god or
goddess. Right. Right.
>> Okay. But now we got a problem. Houston.
And Paul says the same thing, by the
way, that when you take the creature and
worship the creature, not the creator,
corruptible creatures who will perish.
That's what's idolatry. He says it here.
But now watch here. I'm a little
confused because God says to Moses,
"Make them with cherubam." Cherubam are
spirit creatures in heaven. And he tells
Moses, "Make an image of cherubam and
overlay it with gold
and make it as part of the ark of the
covenant." So is God contradicting
himself?
>> No. Cuz he's not telling you to worship.
I was just telling you to
>> But so making an image is not a sin
then, right?
>> Correct. It's if you worship the image,
>> if you worship as a god.
>> Correct.
>> Cuz look what it says here. He made them
cherubam on its two ends. The cherubam
spread out their wings upward covering
the mercy seat with their wings with
their faces toward each other. The face
of cherubam were looking toward the
mercy seat. So God told Moses, "Make
cherubam of gold attached to the mercy
seats which represents my throne in
heaven." If God was against images, then
he contradicts himself. No. Now we got
another problem.
Here's the other problem. Houston
Joshua 7:6
that ark of the covenant mercy seat that
had the cherubam. It says when Joshua
suffered a loss in battle look Joshua 6
Joshua ripped his clothes he and the
Israelite elders fell on their faces to
the ground in front of the ark of the
Lord until evening they bowed down to
that ark that wooden ark with the golden
cherubam. Were they committing idolatry?
>> No. because they were still worshiping
God. They they were just bowing down.
>> Why have a problem with statues? The
Bible doesn't have a problem with
statues. It was a problem with making a
statue or an icon of a creature that you
say this is a god or a goddess.
It's all throughout the Bible. See, I
want to get you the article. In fact,
did you know when God when God told
Moses to build the temple on the walls
of the temple, you know what Solomon
did?
>> No.
He carved images of flowers, images of
cherubam, images
of creatures all throughout the wall.
Here it says, look, he carved on them
cherubam, palm trees, open flowers,
overlaid them with gold, spread gold
upon the cherubam, palm the palm trees.
He carved on the cherubam. He he
deliberately carved images of creatures
on the walls of the temple where God is
worshiped.
There were lions and oxen and cherubam.
If God had a problem with images, why is
God allowing Solomon to take his holy
temple where you worship God and carve
images of spirit creatures of lions and
flowers?
So where's the problem, brother?
>> It's not a problem. It's it's I'm the
problem. Right?
>> So that's the first thing. There's no
problem there. If you understand that
the purpose of the icons and the
statues, not idols, is not, oh, this is
my God. This is a goddess. They are
visible aids
reminding you of these individuals whom
God did great things through, who are
now alive and perfected. and we show
them love and respect because God loves
them and work through them mightily. So
here's the principle in scripture. Now
here's the article for I'm going to send
it to you in private chat and for
everyone else. Here it is. So here it is
in private chat and for you it's right
here.
Christian Coburn, I have a whole series
on this brother Christie or is it
Christian? I don't know how to pronounce
your name. Okay, now what? Let me show
you this.
Why do we love them and honor them and
have these visual aids? So when I see a
picture of Mary, it doesn't matter. She
didn't look like that. I'm associating
that image with Mary. I'll give you
example.
Have you watched movies about Jesus's
life or the life of the prophets?
>> Uh yes.
>> Have you seen cartoons or have you
picked up Bibles with like cartoon
depictions of Jesus and the apostles and
all that?
>> Yes.
>> But Jesus doesn't look like that. Right.
>> Correct.
So, are you sinning by watching a
cartoon, an animated cartoon of a figure
that's not Jesus, but it's meant to be
Jesus or Mary or Moses?
>> No, cuz I know that's a representation,
but it's not.
>> Okay. It's me wearing a cross.
>> That's the issue of the icons. It
doesn't matter whether Mary looks like
that or not. I am associating in my mind
that image with Mary just like when I
see a movie of a Danishl looking Jesus.
Well, Jesus wasn't Danish. He didn't
have green eyes.
>> When I see that actor, I know that actor
is representing Christ. And as such,
I am looking to Christ when I see him.
Or when I see a cartoon of a light
brownhaired Jesus and blue eyes, I know
that's not Jesus. But that animated
cartoon
in my mind makes the connection with
that image and with Christ so that it's
not that image but what that image
points to that I'm focused on. Same
thing with icons and statues. When I see
a statue of Mary, immediately my mind
evokes the holy mother and immediately
my heart is filled with love and
reverence for her. This is the point.
And let me show you from scripture this
point that if you love Jesus, you're
going to love those whom he loves and he
sends. And Jesus says, "If you don't
accept and you don't honor those I sent,
then you don't love me and respect me or
honor me or the father who sent me."
Here you go. Let me show it to you from
scripture.
All right.
Okay. Watch her.
The Matthew 10:40, he who receives you
receives me. He receives me receives him
who sent me. So if I receive Mary, whom
am I receiving?
>> Uh Jesus. Because God because God sent
her.
>> Exactly. In fact, where did Jesus get
his flesh and blood from if not from
Mary?
>> For Mary. Yeah. From Mary. Exactly. So
if I ignore Mary and brush her aside,
you think Jesus is happy with that?
>> No, that's his mother. If I love my
mother, how much more does he love his?
>> Yeah. You got principle. So let's say
you have a son.
I ignore your son. Say, I don't care
about your son. It's about you I care.
What would you say to me?
>> That's my son. How you not going to love
him?
>> Right?
>> If you care about me, you're going to
care about the people that are dear to
my heart.
>> Wow. Okay. So Protestants think they're
doing Jesus a favor by ignoring Mary,
they're not. They're hurting the heart
of Jesus,
>> right? Because that's his mother.
>> Yep. Right.
>> And anyone else, by the way. So when we
honor the saints, why? Cuz they love and
adore Jesus. And Jesus loves and adores
them. Why do you think I even care about
Mary? Because of Jesus. If I didn't care
about Jesus, you think I'd be thinking
about Mary.
>> Wow.
>> Who makes me love her? Jesus. Jesus.
>> Who makes me think about Peter and Paul?
Jesus. If I didn't, if I was an atheist,
do you think I'd care about any of them?
>> Good point.
>> And here it is. Luke 10:16.
>> The one who listens to you listens to
me. The one who rejects you rejects me.
So if you reject Mary, who are you
really rejecting?
>> God. Because he said he he sent her. He
made part of her part of his plan is
Mary.
>> You got it.
>> Right.
>> And he says, "If you reject the one I
sent to you, you're rejecting me."
Right. right here. Luke 10:16.
>> Yep.
>> And he who rejects me rejects my father.
John 13:20. Truly I say to you, he
receives anyone I send receives me. And
he receives me receives him who sent me.
So if I receive Mary because she's of
Jesus, I'm receiving Jesus.
>> Wow. This
>> This is what those who think they're
being Christth honoring miss. I love
Mary because Jesus entered the world
through her. Jesus said, "This is the
woman I'm going to create. This is the
woman I'm going to choose to be my
mother. This is the woman through whom
I'll come into the world because her
flesh will become my flesh. Her blood
will be my blood. Her chromosomes will
be my chromosomes. Her bone will be my
bones. So it's through her I become
flesh. The very flesh that I used to
save you. How do you want me not to love
her?
>> Wow. Okay.
Never thought like that.
>> Okay.
>> How do you want me not to love her?
So this is the key. Go back to your
Catholic root. Let me tell you, brother,
I was Protestant for 20 years. The more
I studied the Bible, the more I studied
church history, the more I realized
the fullness of the truth, the accurate
interpretation of the Bible has always
been with the ancient churches, Catholic
church, Orthodox church, Syan church,
because they go back to the apostles,
and they have a lot more in common than
differences. And since you're Catholic,
go back to your roots. Go home to mother
church. I
>> I will. I will. I'm going to I'm going
to rearch